التطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
باطلاق خمسه صواريخ من القطاع الاوسط من
جنوب لبنان باتجاه مواقع عسكريه اسرائيليه
في الجليل الاعلى وقصفت المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه محيطه بلدات طير حرفا والضير
وشبعه وشنت المقاتلات الاسرائيليه خلال
الساعات ال4 الماضيه غارات على بلدات
مارون الراس وميس الجبل وبليد من جانبه
اعلن حزب الله امس عن مهاجمته سته مواقع و
تجمعات للجنود الاسرائيليين قباله الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان ونعى الحزب ثلاثه من
مقاتليه قال انهم استشهدوا في جنوب
لبنان معنا الان من بلده رميش جنوب لبنان
مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم وايضا من
الجليل الاعلى مراسل الجزيره حسن مسعود
الوقوف على اخر التطورات وايضا التصريحات
ابدا معك مازن
ابراهيم في الواقع ازدهار وفق ايقاع تسير
هذه الجبهه الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان
الايقاع الاول يرتبط بالتطورات الميدانيه
سواء كانت في غزه او عند الحدود الجنوبيه
والايقاع الثاني يرتبط بالمسار السياسي
لناحيه المقترح المتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار
في غزه هذا من جهه ومن جهه ثانيه البعد
السياسي المرتبط بمساعي الموفد الامريكي
امو سكستين الذي يزور المنطقه ويحاول
ترتيب الامور عند هذا الخط الحدودي على
المستوى الميداني العمليات العسكريه هي
تتحرك وفق مسار متصاعد تاره
ومتراعيش شاهدين هنا هذه هذا الضباب هذا
الجو الماطر يؤثر عمليا على العمليات
العسكريه التي ينفذها حزب الله وان كان
صباح اليوم قد اطلق صواريخ باتجاه ثكنه
عسكريه في دوفي في خلفيه هذه الجبال
المطله والتي تظهر في عدسه الكاميرا وايضا
في برعا القوات الاسرائيليه قامت بتوجيه
مدفعيتها وقضائها الى مجموعه من البلدات
اللبنانيه ولكن ينبغي الاشاره الى الى
متغيرات رصدناها خلال الايام الاربعه
الماضيه كثف حزب الله عملياته في مزارع
شبعه المحتله ولالك فرشو المحتله عندما
رصدنا خلال الايام الاربعه الماضيه تنفيذ
حزب الله 19 عمليه عسكريه كان 11 عمليه
منها في مزارع شبعه لماذا هذا الامر مهم
لانه ياتي مع زياره الموفد الامريكي امس
وكستين الى المنطقه وبالتالي هنالك رساله
واضحه من هذه العمليات العسكريه المكثفه
في المنطقه التي يعتبرها لبنان محتله بان
اي مسار تفاوضي هو لا يمكن ان يشرع في
لبنان الا ضمن محددين المحدد الاول انتهاء
العمليه العسكريه والعدوان الاسرائيلي على
قطاع غزه هذا من جهه ومن جهه ثانيه ان فتح
ملف الحدود اللبنانيه من قبل الوسيط
الامريكي ام سكستين لا يمكن ان يغفل مزارع
شبعه ولالك فرشو المحتله بالاضافه الى
منطقه الغجر هذه النقطه بالغت الاهميه
لذلك تم تكثيف العمليات العسكريه ل من قبل
حزب الله في تلك المنطقه من خلال استخدام
الصواريخ بالامس يتحدث عن صواريخ بركان
فلق وغيرها من هذه الصواريخ الثقيله التي
يتم توجيهها باتجاه تلك المنطقه في
استهداف واضح للقوات قوات الاحتلال الاسرا
في مزارع شبعه المحتله عمليا ضمن المسار
السياسي الان هذه الجبهه تتحرك بانتظار ما
قد يرشح خلال الايام المقبله حول احتماليه
وقف العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه هذا من
جهه وبعجز يرتبط ايضا بان وصول ام سكسين
الى اسرائيل ومنها الى بيروت في زياره
مرتقبه ومحتمل فهنالك تاكيد من حزب الله
بان اي طرح لا يمكن ان يقتصر على النقاط
ال 13 عند الخط الحدودي مختلف عليها ولكن
يجب ان تشمل مزارع شبعه وتلال كفر شوبه
اللبنانيه المحتله